gosto dos sons e do significado das
palavras
geralmente antes de escrever procuro
desmembrá-la para que me ajudem a dar
sentido nas minhas ideias ea palavra que
dá início nesta conversa importar que é
o movimento para dentro do que tem
importância
sendo assim a frase mais acertada seria
porque existem pessoas que simplesmente
não importam os outros para sua vida
simples
trazemos para a nossa vida o que tem
significado que faz sentido que nos faça
feliz bem e melhor
cada um tem seu motivo suas razões e
significados
sou da época em que me comunicavam com
os amigos mais distantes por meio de
cartas que demoravam demais para chegar
hoje vivemos a era do já agora ea
palavra imediatamente nem cabe seu
significado porque a gente demora para
pronunciar a substituírem as cartas por
tempo real pela comunicação nas redes
sociais veja em tempo real quando as
pessoas ficam indignados com cenas de
cachorros abandonados crianças
maltratadas mulheres marcadas pela
violência doméstica desmatamento entre
outras
ou seja as pessoas se importam ou
exportam constantemente informações
pedem um homem
pergunto com os curtir essa criança com
deficiência merece distribuem petições
que nem sabemos ao certo se são reais
afirma que os gênios das redes sociais
vão doar para cada curtida enfim uma
infinidade de ações virtuais
claro que existem muitas ações com
resultados surpreendentes mas a maioria
não ultrapassa o mundo virtual e quando
nos deparamos com cenas que não queremos
ver basta clicar em não quero ver isso
sensacional porque o que os olhos não
vêem o coração não sente
situação resolvida mas o mundo ainda
continua caótico
sou uma pessoa indignada por natureza as
coisas me incomodam e quando incomodam
preciso de respostas e para ter
respostas faço perguntas
e só minha quieto quando analisa as
respostas até entender e foi isso que
fiz
pedi ajuda dos meus amigos na rede
social para compreender o motivo pelo
qual existem pessoas que simplesmente
não se importa com o sofrimento do outro
foi respostas interessantes e
semelhantes ditas de formas diferentes
li análise às respostas e cheguei nesses
dois grupos o que tem o que falta no
comportamento das pessoas que inibe o
movimento para dentro o importar
falta amor fé respeito valores
familiares e sociais sensibilidade
empatia gentileza limites e conexão com
o outro
temos uma educação ea educação eu me
refiro a responsabilidade da família que
inter me habilita o sentimento dos
filhos porque procuro de todas as formas
neutralizar a frustração por meio de
recursos que os mantenham em constante
alegria e bem estar
a criança deve vivenciar o significado
dos 55 e não como não existem lares onde
quem manda suas crianças
dessa forma essas crianças se tornam
pessoas que alimenta o relacionamento
desde que sejam descartáveis porque se
algo não é do jeito que querem é fácil
resolver deleta se temos pressa muita
pressa para chegar chegar onde quem
ficou para ouvir a resposta tornamo-nos
alienados afinal não é comigo da
preguiça porque é preciso ser mais do
que a indignação
o medo nos protege de muitos enganos e
de muitas ações também ambição educamos
para ter e como resultado nos tornamos
egoístas também tem como resultado
muitas pessoas que se escondem atrás das
piadas inverteu significado rir é o
melhor remédio mas reduz o outro não
cura não salva não alivia e uma que
residia resume tudo todo esse grupo é
ter uma visão deturpada do mundo
alguns foram solidários ao afirmar que
muitos não se importam porque se exige
coragem ação disposição e um olhar
sensível apenas alguns indicadores em
falta nos tempos atuais
isso me faz
pensar que são indicadores que já
existiram e que estão adormecidos gostei
disso é uma oportunidade para sermos
fonte de inspiração e isso despertar e
de forma mais direta que não adianta
exigir das pessoas mas o que elas podem
oferecer isso me soou como um alerta
porque talvez algumas pessoas também
precise de alguém que assim porte ea
conclusão é a de que são dois os ícones
que respondem à minha pergunta
o primeiro é o umbigo sim ele passa a
ser o centro do universo
muitos se referiram a ele dessa forma as
pessoas se importam porque esse pó se
preocupa com o próprio umbigo e para
ilustrar esse só se importa com o
próprio umbigo encontrei alguns elfos
interessantes
self é uma das palavras do momento é a
famosa foto umbigo que você tira de si
mesmo para apostar nas redes sociais
nada mais acertado do que ter um self do
próprio umbigo
o segundo é estar acima do bem e do mal
e cada um tem um significado do que é
bem e do que é mau
geralmente usamos a ausência para
compreender a existência é na ausência
da luz que existe escuridão na ausência
do bem ou mal
alguns me responderam que era falta de
amor ao próximo a deus aos deuses ao ser
humano
seguindo pela mesma linha de raciocínio
a ausência do amor seria o ódio será
mesmo as pessoas que não se importam
seriam as rodeiam
ou seriam apenas pessoas que se importam
com a própria vida ao nosso bem maior
a própria vida estariam essas pessoas
erradas ao cuidar do seu bem mais
precioso
costumamos por hábito generalizar tudo e
todos
isso nos fazem tolerantes se não me
importo significa que não amamos a frase
amar ao próximo próximo é bem mais fácil
do que amar o próximo distante
julgamos avaliamos o fazemos observações
em relação ao comportamento dos que
estão vivendo a própria vida sem sermos
solidários
talvez nele não se importe porque não
sabe o que fazer porque talvez não dê
conta do que é preciso fazer
porque talvez ele precise de alguém que
se importe com ele se importar
a escolha assim como amar a escolha
incomodados mudam o mundo será algumas
pessoas esperam o mundo mudar
outras buscam formas para mudar o mundo
e descobrem que é preciso mudar se
primeiro para a mudança que precisa ser
acontecer a um grande e significativo
número de pessoas incomodadas indignados
com o cenário mundial e só seu incômodo
terminal mudar de canal
ao bloquear a imagem em seu mural nas
redes sociais
ao virar a página de jornal incomodados
mudou o mundo e as pessoas são
responsáveis por essa mudança será
quando chama os altruístas acabamos
exercendo algo para atender ao nosso ego
e ficamos indignados ao economizar água
para os que desperdiçou essa riqueza
porque não temos como separar mas
acredito que muito já pensava em como
ter duas torneiras uma para os que
economizo e outra para os que
desperdiçara eu já pensei isso porque
exercitamos esse pensamento siafi afinal
nos importamos com o outro
até agora ninguém respondeu que não sou
porque não quero ser
seria o meu umbigo diferente do seu e
ser solidário parece que traz
silenciosamente o direito de querer
mudar as pessoas para que elas também
seja esquecemos que toda mudança nasce a
partir do próprio umbigo
as pessoas mudam porque querem mudar
porque deseja mudar ou porque precisa
mudar qualquer coisa fora desse contexto
é apenas um agradar a quem nos pediu
para mudar é preciso saber quem sou para
ter conhecimento do que me deixa
confortável e minhas escolhas
essa é a base de todo o processo é única
pessoal e intransferível ela é umbilical
e foi assim que construí minha jornada
uma coisa verdadeira foram os planos que
não deram certo que me trouxeram até
aqui
o plano conhecer o mundo era bem
interessante mas foi sendo adaptado
alterado cada vez que a vida trazia
outros desafios
os desencontros aumentar o número de
páginas do meu currículo profissional
porque precisei aprender sobre tantos
outros assuntos
aprendi a recomeçar e quantas vezes já
recomecei sei lá deixa de contar faz
algum tempo porque descobri que a única
interessada nessa contagem era dupla
tristeza e frustração
coloquei prazo de validade não gosta que
todo recomeço trás e seguir adiante
e tem sido assim afinal descobrem o
mundo que existem pessoas com histórias
de recomeço muito maiores que a minha e
sente vergonha de mim mesma
sem desvalorizar meu sentimento de perda
aprendi com os que tinham perdido muito
mais
uma das coisas que me encanta nas
pessoas é a capacidade que tem ser
resilientes e como mesmo precisando de
ajuda ela se importavam para as suas
vidas
isso é maravilhoso seria máxima sorri
que o mundo sorrirá de volta estendida
para se importe que as pessoas
importaram você
no primeiro exemplo de importar uma
pessoa foi aos seis anos de idade quando
vi minha mãe lavando uma maneira suja
tentando fazer milagres e que por final
decidiu jogar fora e ir à farmácia do
bairro
naquela época existiam as cadernetas por
isso não ter dinheiro não impediria da
copa e essa mamadeira não era pra
ninguém de casa mas que uma criança
estava nos braços de mordoma moradora de
rua ela estava sentada em nossa calçada
com mais duas crianças ao seu redor
naquela atitude hoje sei estava a
mensagem de que podemos ser mais para
alguém se resolvermos ser mais do nosso
melhor
é preciso antes de tudo ser humano para
exercitar a escuta do humano que está à
sua frente
minhas experiências de desencontros
tornaram-se pontuou indicador para
compreender a dor do outro e
principalmente para dimensionar que as
linhas são pequenas
somos comparação constante é assim o
processo que usamos para pensou em
mensurar algo
aquilo é grande em relação à que aqui e
ao fazer essa comparação fique tinha
muito mais agradecer do que a cultivar
dores mágoa e tristeza
abracem muitas mães ao chorar ea perda
de seus filhos adolescentes que se
desesperaram por perderem o desejo de
viver
vi pessoas perderem imagem que o tempo
com os seus 20 pessoas perderem sonhos e
com isso suas vidas e nessa jornada
descubro que sofre que a sabedoria entre
tantas dores é o caminho do meio
não importa seus títulos porque adorava
lapidar sua alma e quando nos deparamos
com a beleza dessa lapidação aceitamos
que apesar dos pesares
mesmo sem desejar nos tornamos sábios
orgulhe-se da sabedoria que lapidar o
até esse exato momento de suas vidas
reconheceu que fizeram um lindo trabalho
sejam generosos consigo mesmo aprendendo
a dosar o orgulho para que não se torne
vaidade pessoas vaidosas preenchem todo
o espaço no espelho com a própria imagem
e não sobra espaço para mais pessoas
a sabedoria de que não salvaria o mundo
é real mas a consciência de que assumir
a responsabilidade em construir um
legado é tão concreta quanto o desejo em
ser mais no meu melhor
talvez o melhor seja apenas 1% do seu
melhor e que importância isso tem
nenhuma importante atitude ser o melhor
que se pudesse ser entre tantas
reflexões este fim coven a que mais me
inspira é viver amar ri e deixar um
legado
os primeiros verbas fazem sentido e
minha vida e muito mas esse tal delegado
seria a construção de uma praça um
obelisco uma colecção literária após
refletir muito descobri e acredito que
legado seja o que ficará após sairmos de
cena o que ficará na memória das pessoas
qual a marca que eu você deixaremos o
mundo tem me preocupado com pessoas faz
muito tempo e desde 2009 vem
redesenhando algo que pudesse ser mais
sólido mas o que uma mulher de fases ou
mudanças constantes que me conhece sabe
disso respeito mudança de ideias de
pensamento vida é constante
dança e nessas mudanças de idéias e
pensamentos
o rascunho do que viria ser concreto nas
a partir do universo das pessoas com
deficiência importa preocupação com os
direitos humanos o que era figura passou
a ser um dos temas transversais nessa
missão em 2013 na substituto entre rodas
e button
tudo tem um tempo motivo para ser o
instituto entre rodas e button
nasceu no momento certo para segmentar
uma discussão que trata de direitos
humanos e todas as formas de violência e
propor uma tecnologia social porque o
instituto porque sim para sensibilizar
inspirar e mobilizar pessoas na formação
de líderes humanitárias para a igualdade
de gênero pessoas mudam o mundo mas para
isso acontecer é preciso ser mais do que
planos o mundo que queremos ser uma
resposta significativa quando responder
mas de forma sincera à pergunta qual o
mundo que eu quero essa resposta é
subjetivo é particular é sua é minha é o
mundo que queremos ou o mundo que eu
quero
essa é uma criança desenhar o mundo que
ela quer ela importará para dizer o que
tem significado e sentido para ela com
certeza será diferente dos nossos
desenhos e se não fizer sentido algum
pra mim ou pra você não tem problema
algum porque é importante é que faça
sentido para quem idealizou
somos seres de luz e sombra tudo depende
da nossa escolha
as escolhas que faço precisam fazer
sentido pra mim e pra mais ninguém
porque elas precisam me dar o conforto
que a minha consciência vai apresentar
todas as vezes que me olhar no espelho
o tempo me ensinou que as respostas que
fazem sentido são as mais simples
foi um processo interessante chegar à
fase da simplicidade beirando o
simplório exigiu compromisso com a forma
que eu olhava o mundo e as pessoas
a simplicidade é o último grau de
sofisticação disse tão sabiamente
leonardo da vinci exercício diário que
me fazem ampliar cada vez mais o olhar
pra
descobrir novos ângulos e encontrar
novas respostas
decidi escolher ser mais simples da
leitura do mundo talvez eu nunca
conquiste isso por completo mas tudo bem
afinal são os desejos que me coloca em
movimento
apesar de tantos desalinhos e
desencontros que ainda existem no mundo
gosto do que vejo e sei que ainda muito
por fazer apenas ficar incomodada com as
histórias não alimenta minha alma tenho
fome de muito mais que você escolha ser
o seu melhor por desejo próprio viva o
seu umbigo seja o centro do universo sim
mas tem a consciência de que tudo é ação
e reação e que a partir do seu umbigo
você se relaciona com os outros amigos
pessoas muda o mundo quando se permitem
ser o seu melhor escolher gratidão amor
e alegria porque me fortalece para viver
e por sua atenção sou grata